every form of life suffers mama and
little baby deer thing are just going
for a stroll in the woods and they get
ambushed by a lioness
of course it's a lion you know like some
kind of safari in Africa boom I'm not
gonna play the Audio I don't need to
feed you the audio but you know little
Bambi here is is making some noises that
you probably don't want this is life you
know
life
includes pain
it's it's just it's just a grim reality
of you know
the universe man whatever it is you want
to call it [__] comes and goes dinosaurs
dealt with some serious pain when the
[__] asteroid hit the Earth right
wipe them all out clean
every forb of Life suffers you're not
unique you're not special you're not you
know some kind of like leprechaun
rainbows and butterflies
special breed of whatever
you're like anything else on this Earth
you're alive you breathe the air at some
point we all you know we all wrap up
every human is gonna suffer
every human experience is obstacles you
know one of the things that um
I know it's my granddad or my dad that
told me this first it might have come
vis-a-vis my granddad you know down on
my dad but he always said something
along the lines of there's always
somebody out there that would be happy
to train trade places with you so it
doesn't matter what you're moping about
what you think you're you know you've
got pain in whatever it is that might be
you know making your day your week your
month your year [__] or whatever you
want to call it
I guarantee there's not just one there's
probably not a dozen it's probably not a
hundred there's probably not a thousand
but probably tens of thousands maybe
even hundreds of thousands of people
that would trade their shitty life their
their worse off circumstances for
whatever it is that you're complaining
about right now so perspective is an
important thing to consider here again
every human experiences obstacles and
suffering
um one of the grand mistakes that I hear
a lot of people
make because they seem to think that you
know life is against yours trying to
sabotage your happiness
um there was a three-letter acronym that
was used a lot
I don't see it too much anymore but it
was used a lot maybe 10 15 years ago FML
which stood for f my life
right something bad would happen pain
would come your way suffering something
didn't go well FML you know that was
like an abbreviated text form that got
sent around all the time
and it's like you know the the crowd
that's like oh God is against me [__] my
life you know like life really isn't
trying to sabotage anything for you
realistically more often than not a lot
of the a lot of the
I'm gonna put this without hurting too
many snowflakes
it's probably your fault I'm just gonna
say it I mean
the vast majority of of problems that
you're dealing with your life it's
probably your fault okay there's there's
rare circumstances where it's not your
fault you know where you
end up dealing with some [__] and it's
like okay that one wasn't my like I I
have 30 burns like on my chest here this
happened when I was a toddler I was like
a year and a half pulled a kettle hot
water on myself you know I don't have
any memory of it you know thankfully
that wasn't my fault you know I'll admit
that but but pretty much everything
beyond that point you know when you have
Consciousness when you have memory when
you have some decision-making capacity
if you're a 10 year old
and you're ripping
um
so my first skateboard so you know this
is a great story because my parents have
a picture of me on their wall with these
three scars down my uh face forehead and
and like slashes down my nose
um because when I got my first
skateboard
um I don't know I think it's great five
or something like that but they have
like literally the school picture
because I did it three days before the
school picture happened so the class
picture and like the headshot there I am
with the big scars on my face and um I
was on my knee and I was pushing up the
driveway and I had a rock and I went
flying over the skateboard and smashed
my face into the uh ground that was my
fault it's not it's not my parents fault
for not sweeping the driveway clear of
stones that was that was a lesson that I
needed to learn pretty much everything
we do in our life
you know when we deal with chaos when we
deal with pain when we deal with
something that doesn't go our way it's
our fault and you know you can either
learn from it or you can lose you know
you can just sit there and complain
about it
um
just trying to cross off some of these
talking points that I made here for
today
yeah so your mind is one of your biggest
obstacles too
you know to be honest with you because
I don't I don't know how many movies
I've seen this used in but it's but it's
an old story about The Wolf of light and
the Wolf of Darkness right and you know
the question goes
um you know which one wins in combat you
know essentially you know the wolf of
light or the wolf of darkness and the
answer to the question is always
whichever one you feed right so a lot of
the times
chaos problem pain you know something
that comes your way it's usually a
result of you know like which side are
you leaning on like are you leaning on
greatness are you leaning on achievement
are you leaning on ownership are you
leaning on winning are you leaning on
being a victim being a little [__]
about it uh crying pointing and
sputtering other people and blaming them
you know for things
um your mind's usually your biggest
obstacle you're you're gonna be honest
with you pretty much everything you get
in your life all all your
accomplishments all your failures
everything
pretty much relies on you you know
there's a lot of people out there today
that are blaming the government their
boss their spouse their whatever you
know
if it's your boss well you chose to work
there you're the one that applied for
the job if it's your spouse well you
you're the one that chose them you know
men are The Gatekeepers of relationships
you're the guy who's mostly dudes
watching my channel you're the guy
you made the decision to invite her into
your life right government well you can
always pick up and move and leave you
know if you don't like the situation
that you're in right so
use your mind for more more productive
things you know find find solution I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
you know choosing a lot of the stuff
that comes your way when it comes to
painting suffering
another point that I wanted to make is
making mountains out of mole Hills right
a lot of um a lot of dudes will
make big deals out of small things and I
don't think
I think there's a little bit of a
difference with the Sexes you know
sometimes guys do it more than women but
I think overall uh
you know the weaker softer
folks out there because there's we can
soft men too for being honest
you know I'm a victim uh you know as
well complaining like zero stuff right
like zero-sum game stuff making
mountains out of moles when things don't
really need to matter that much
it happens it happens you know a lot of
people do it and it's unnecessary
making a big deal out of nothing make a
big deal out of something make make a
big deal out of something that is going
to
complicate your life if somebody puts
your
you know put your life put your momentum
put your business in danger
okay
make a mountain out of that you know if
you need to right learn how to walk away
identify problem errors identify problem
people you get better at as you get
older you know you're gonna sure you're
gonna make some mistakes you're gonna
invite some
[__] in your life maybe in your 20s
probably into your 30s maybe even into
your 40s probably gonna deal with some
low value women that are going to
complicate your life unnecessarily
definitely in your 20s maybe in your 30s
probably even some of you into your 40s
I mean the whole reason why I wrote my
book The unplugged Alpha and I put the
chapter in there with the 20 red flags
to help you guys avoid that stuff so
you're not gonna invite pain into your
life which some people like to amplify
into suffering again pain is going to be
mandatory suffering is an option you
don't have to suffer if you don't want
to I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out